president biden's call on all americans
to stand up to bigotry
the president and vice president kamala
harris speaking out friday during a
visit to atlanta the scene
of tuesday's mass shooting that left
eight people dead
the remarks came after a meeting with
asian american leaders to address
growing violence against their community
during the coronavirus pandemic
of the eight people killed at the three
separate atlantis spas
seven were women and six were of asian
descent
on friday authorities identified the
last of the victims
jesse mitchell is in atlanta covering it
like always jessie good morning
good morning michelle that meeting with
the president and vice president lasted
more than an
hour and while a coven 19 hate crime
bill was discussed
the meeting focused more on the grief
and fear people in the asian american
community are feeling right now
words have consequences
it's the car it's the coronavirus full
stop
president biden specifically tying the
pandemic to the spike in violence
against asian americans
while imploring americans to take a
stand against
racism and bigotry hate and violence
often hide in plain sight it's often met
with silence
that's been through throughout our
history but that has to change
because our silence is complicity kamala
harris the nation's first vice president
of south asian descent
also speaking out saying everyone has
the right to be
safe and also the right
to be recognized as an american
not as the other hours earlier police
released the names of four people gunned
down at two spas in atlanta
all were asian women ranging in age from
51
to 74. soon chung park
suncha kim young a you and
hyun chung grant her son randy park
wrote about his loss
losing her has put a new lens on the
amount of hate
in our world but those murders are not
classified as a hate crime so far by
authorities
we're also learning more about the
alleged gunman robert
aaron long records show he legally
purchased the gun
on the same day of the shootings and
deputies in the jail where lung is being
held say
as he was going into his cell he asked
if he would spend the rest of his life
in prison
according to police long told
investigators he was not fueled by
racism however state and federal hate
crime charges could still be filed
his first court appearance has yet to be
set
jeff jesse mitchell thank you very much